Mis tres minutos aún no han comenzado, ¿verdad?.
Chris Anderson: No, no puedes reiniciar los 3 minutos
Reinicia los 3 minutos, no es justo.
Allison Hunt: Ay Dios, qué estrictos son aquí.
¡Ya estoy nerviosa de por sí!
Pero no estoy tan nerviosa como hasta hace 5 semanas.
Hace 5 semanas tuve una cirugía de reemplazo total de cadera.
¿Saben algo acerca de esta operación?
Sierra eléctrica, taladro, muy desagradable.
Salvo que uno sea David Bolinsky, en cuyo caso todo es un camino de rosas.
Si, David, cuando no se trata de tu propia cadera, todo es un camino de rosas.
Pues bien, yo tuve una gran revelación con este asunto,
y Chris me invitó aquí a contárselas.
Pero en primer lugar, deben saber dos cosas acerca de mí.
Sólo dos cosas.
Soy canadiense y soy la más pequeña de siete hermanos.
En Canadá contamos con un gran sistema de salud.
Esto significa que nos dan caderas nuevas sin costo alguno.
Y yo, al ser la más pequeña de siete,
nunca estuve en primer lugar en ninguna fila, ¿OK?
Hacía años que me dolía la cadera.
Finalmente fui al doctor; la consulta era sin costo.
y ella me remitió al cirujano ortopédico, también sin costo.
Finalmente pudo atenderme luego de 10 meses de espera, casi un año.
Estos son los beneficios de un servicio gratuito.
Fui a ver al cirujano, quien me sacó algunas radiografías sin costo.
Las miré bien y, en realidad,
hasta yo me daba cuenta de que mi cadera estaba mal.
Y eso que yo me dedico al mercadeo.
Entonces me dijo: "Allison, vamos a tener que operarte.
Te voy a poner una nueva cadera, tendrás que esperar unos 18 meses.
18 meses más.
Ya había esperado 10 meses y debía esperar 18 meses más.
Era una espera tan larga que prácticamente
comencé a calcular el tiempo en base a la cantidad de TEDs.
No tendría mi cadera nueva para este TED,
Tendría mi nueva cadera para la sesión de TEDGlobal en África,
No tendría mi cadera nueva para TED2008.
Todavía estaría soportando mi pobre cadera. Era muy desalentador.
Así es que me fui de su oficina, y mientras caminaba por el hospital,
en ese momento tuve mi revelación.
La más pequeña de siete hermanos debía colocarse en el primer lugar de la fila.
¡Si!
¿Saben lo anti-canadiense que es esto?
Nosotros no pensamos así.
No hablamos de eso, ni lo consideramos.
De hecho, cuando viajamos al extranjero, así identificamos a nuestros compatriotas canadienses.
"Después de Ud." "No, no. Después de Ud."
¿Usted es Canadiense? "¡Ah, yo también! ¡¿Qué tal?!
"¡Perfecto!" "¡Qué bueno!"
Así es que, de pronto ya no me molestaba tener que eliminar a algún abuelo de la lista.
Algún anciano de 70 años que quería su cadera nueva,
para poder seguir jugando al golf o arreglando su jardín.
No, no. Al primer lugar de la fila.
A esta altura ya estaba yo en la recepción y obviamente con dolor,
me dolía mi cadera, y como que necesitaba una señal.
Y entonces vi la señal.
En la vidriera de una pequeña tienda de regalos del hospital estaba la señal
y decía: "Se necesitan voluntarios". Mmmm.
Pues me contrataron inmediatamente.
No pidieron referencias, ni verificaron ninguna información como se hace normalmente.
Estaban desesperados por encontrar voluntarios:
la edad promedio de los voluntarios que trabajaban en la tienda de regalos del hospital, era de 75 años.
Definitivamente necesitaban sangre joven.
Y así, de un momento a otro, ya tenía puesto mi uniforme azul de voluntario.
Tenía mi foto identificatoria y había sido entrenada por mi jefe de 89 años.
Trabajaba sola.
Cada viernes por la mañana acudía a la tienda de regalos.
MIentras les vendía pastillitas de menta al personal del sanatorio,
casualmente preguntaba: "¿A qué se dedica usted?"
Y luego les contaba: "A mi me van a operar de la cadera...dentro de 18 meses.
Será fantástico el día que no me duela más. ¡Ayyy!
Todo el personal conoció a la joven y valiente voluntaria.
Casualmente mi próxima consulta con el cirujano
tenía lugar justo a la salida de uno de mis turnos en la tienda.
Por lo tanto yo llevaba puesto mi uniforme y mi identificación.
Coloqué ambas cosas despreocupadamente sobre la silla del consultorio del doctor.
Y cuando entró
me di cuenta de que los vio claramente.
MInutos más tarde, ya tenía fecha para operarme algunas semanas después,
y una buena receta de Percocet.
Digamos que lo que se dijo por allí
fue que mi trabajo como voluntaria fue lo que me llevó a adelantarme en la fila.
¿Y saben qué? ni siquiera mi avergüenzo de eso.
Por dos razones.
La primera: no se imaginan cómo voy a cuidar a mi cadera nueva.
Pero además, pretendo seguir trabajando como voluntaria,
lo cual me lleva a la principal revelación:
Incluso cuando burlamos el sistema, los canadienses
lo hacen de manera tal que la sociedad se ve beneficiada.